walk to the window to the wall hello
everybody my name is markiplier and
welcome to frosty nights now this game
was made by the same person that made
boogey man and if you remember boogey
man it was a scary game that was an
offshoot of some sort of five nights at
Freddy's type game that then became a
beast of its own but this is completely
different as far as I know maybe I don't
know and there's a mystery door what
could be inside I don't know I can't I
can't open I just want to vibrate very
intensely on this door okay alright can
I can I not go into it
okay well boy or girl well this is
[ __ ] only boy and girl option
where's the man option cuz I'm a man we
said they'd come Oh think of my man oh
I'll choose boy like that this doesn't
lead nowhere what about girl no it's no
good either
I'll go the boy I'm a big boy I am a big
brave boy Oh pick up interact II for
them glad these floating instructions
are okay they're gone oh oh I know what
to do here oh I'm glad it snaps in place
I wouldn't know what to do otherwise am
I about to create my demon here is this
me oh [ __ ] didn't mean to do that that
fast I meant to put this on first that
would have been weird elbow and I scarf
and then the magic hat to bring you to
life this is how the story goes so I'm
assuming this is gonna cause you to turn
into a demon oh I could kill you if I
just push your head off okay no nothing
on your body oh oh I'm not done oh let's
get this I'm gonna throw it up that
ain't working okay let's give you arms I
guess let's give you nice arms with
which to strangle me whoo I think you're
done oh I'm going steadily blah
well goodbye cruel world
Oh yep I passed out in the middle of the
field now I'm looking straight up okay
oh oh now we get going yay all right
show me what you got come on I'm ready I
told you I'm a big brave boy clockwork
wolf or clockwork eight wolf or qual
quality never mind somebody there's so
many cool Christmas games that I didn't
play because I took a nice vacation and
then went immediately on tour for
Christmas
oh that's not good oh I didn't even
notice the deer good god it's it
actually startled me and I have no idea
why hi dear how you doing you doing good
no don't look at my house don't be
jealous of what I got just because
you're a stupid deer and lives outside
and me have a mature what the oh I
cannot tell what kind of wildlife is out
there I've never even been outside I
don't even know what an owl looks like
what other animals can I identify that's
a deer that's a foul
that's a murderous snowman that's a mile
who's that's a star alrighty then whoa
what's this story time I hid my story
tapes around my room to stop my mom
finding them that [ __ ] I'm not sleepy
yet I might find them and play them in
my tape player cuz I got nothing better
to do I won't have time to listen to
them again I have five tapes I'm so glad
that I wrote all this information down
for myself I wouldn't forget about mine
own tape okay you know they give you
nightmares
thanks for not coming in my room and
giving me some privacy to myself I'm
good for we're not gonna loosen the new
boobs
do I have a flashlight or anything what
is this what do I have here what so this
then oh tape no no no if that's useful
at all let's see if my claws
Narnia or some demonic equivalent was
this a Raygun the hairdryer why would I
have an array gun and/or this looks
actually like a hairdryer oh oh I can
use it in defense and ever pick it up
again never ever ever can I pick this
goddamn thing up again
I can use it in defense of frosty
because I can melt him can I go in my
closet Oh
squeaky I can't see [ __ ] I can't see
[ __ ] I'll never know where I hit
anything is that a book at whoa Kate's
gone oh there we go please yes ah
perfect
okay anything in there hello hello hello
well that's weird
so far so nothing I can't even find a
single one of them well okay like what
did I just I don't know what I did what
did I do
what oh okay action plan before each
night I should search for useful items
put them where they will help best
offensive position to start the night
but what got a child stratagem am i
coming up with what kind of battle
general am i all right well let's go
find some useful [ __ ] oh no come on
now okay
the selection process is a little buggy
there we go that's good wait do I have a
hair dryer duct tape my hairdresser
chapter would welcome children to a
wonderful magical Saint Nicholas never
wanted you to know okay story takes us
back a long long time ago when old
Nicholas still had flexes ginger and his
beard we'll just call him by what
everyone today know him as Santa aha
start from the very beginning
when Santa was still scouring the world
for the perfect place to build his
workshop he found none better than the
North Pole where garsik seeped readily
from the earth oh I got as much magic
was there that Santa learn to use the
magic in ways he had never dreamt his
body no longer grew old he could slow
time around him to a near complete stop
and as long as he gathered enough magic
he knew he could travel the world in
what to us was a single day even slowing
time as he could Santa quickly realized
to make enough toys for every child in
the world would take him far too long so
Santa placed his hands into the snow and
called to Mother Nature herself for help
Mother Nature was gentle as she was wild
she saw the kindness in Santa's heart
and agreed to help by melding Santa's
magic and mother nature's spirit into
the snow itself the first of the snowmen
bubbled up from the ground like liquid
snow yet unmoving in lifeless just as
the Snowman we know today mother nature
seemed to pause before then placing a
carrot for its nose you see everything
that is alive requires a small part of
life to begin with the Acorn for the oak
tree the egg for the Red Robin and the
love of a mother and father for Humanity
the carrot twitched and ever so slowly
eyes within the sphere of snow began to
appear and opened for the first time
okay Santa slanted his head to the side
in a curious thinking gaze as he took
off his scarf and hat and placed it upon
the snowman taking a step back he looked
again and smiled the Snowman smiled back
as Santa the father and mother nature as
the mother the Snowman were
all too happy to help Santa what getting
on the bed maybe uh I was still
listening to the story about saying
Mother Nature got freakin shot out of
snow man oh man I understand where that
story went oh I it's it's begun I go oh
okay
I don't that was it that was a long-ass
intro to get to this part of the game
you guys may not have seen all of it
because why why why how do i what
I got hairdryer I guess what Oh
oh dear no don't go near the Snowman oh
no that deer ain't happy no don't repeat
what Santa and mother nature did to make
that snowman in the first place okay no
no don't go near no don't go near no
dear no oh it's fine okay never mind
then what about that owl that all that I
saw oh there it is okay whoa what the
[ __ ] did that worker did that not how
can I tell you're a like I don't even
understand okay we're doing great
apparently I don't know if we're doing
great but it feels good yeah hey whoa
whoa whoa whoa hey why did that's not
normal um um oh sure well hey I don't
know about that oh well okay
can I nope can't do nothing oh oh
is there something actually gotta happen
around I already this is one of those
systems where I'm already dead my WOM oh
she dead
the hit stop stop stop
Wow what did I do
oh did that do anything it's getting
awfully cold in here now you loved it in
a draft my mom's gonna kill me about
this heating bill replace that I guess
replace anything would only replace it a
little bit
that's not how flashlights work oh boy
there's gotta be like some strategy
right it's probably gonna end at 6:00
a.m. but these two windows are open
which usually in any other case would
spell death for me but I ain't dead
hello rat how you doing at least I got a
good B to blow weapon that's the only
thing that I can be happy about whoa
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
that's not really it's a ghost
basketball I don't even know where you
came from
oh whoa [ __ ] toe Jesus oh my god that
that scared the piss out of me
I thought I was dead okay all right
thank you shut up shut up shut up okay
all right okay hey we're all smiling
here all right okay okay oh I can see
how that would be a problem okay
[Laughter]
happened and why I'm missing some
careful context of why all right I just
look for things that make noises and try
to put them in places that will alert me
from where the snowman is coming from
I'll need to get back into bed when I'm
finished ding-a-ling playing a ping
squeeze
sure can I make my sweet hybrid gun
again cuz that was oh man let me tell
you something that was delightful okay I
can't get in this thing I'm looking
right at you and you are not ah there we
go okay
ring a ling a ding ding can I just all
right you know that's probably good
enough well it's gonna have to be good
enough because I can't ever get again oh
okay well that's I'm alright [ __ ]
really I can't oh there we go okay
[Music]
that'll do now can I can I find the
goddamn cassette because that's really
what I'm looking for here whoa whoa whoa
you're not supposed to be doing that yet
are you I don't know is the night going
what no it's not shut up [ __ ] you go
away [ __ ]
oh there's some ringa Linga ding chimes
now how do i oh
can't get out of room now okay how do I
Jesus how do i how do i string this up
what do we do okay whatever ringa linga
ding is good enough okay I guess that's
good enough okay well I had a batteries
on this bad boy can I grab one of these
no I guess just out okay great is if
there's a tape in here I'll never know
Oh squeaky peaky big he's squeaky all
right
you right there squeakums all right well
I guess I'm as ready as I'll ever be but
I won't I want to know the story just
tell me the story why do you why are you
making the story something that's just
like oh maybe you'll find out wokai
where how did I teleport from that
didn't make any goddamn sense all right
whatever you know what mom please Oh
we put happen to my chimes what what
happened to my chimes what the [ __ ] all
right whatever you know what [ __ ] it
is going on the bed because apparently
that's how or or not okay or not okay or
not did I just kick my bear out of the
way I can't see [ __ ] [ __ ] what the
[ __ ] is happening what the [ __ ] what the
[ __ ] game he's serious I can't see [ __ ]
I don't know what you want from me game
what do you want well there they are
[ __ ] okay so they gotta go in specific
places you can't just put them
willy-nilly like I thought okay well
that's there now where's my goddamn bear
it's in here somewhere
but I can't see [ __ ] diddly so I'll
never [ __ ] now I'll never find it
there's no [ __ ] way I'll ever find it
again can I just can I just start over
can I just start over
can I just is there any way I could just
start over can I start over
main menu can I start over and not from
the beginning of the game I'm just
talking about from where I was okay
continue yes please no not this [ __ ]
get out of my face I don't care about
this I'm sorry I'm sorry okay I'm sorry
I'm not mad I'm not mad because of the
game I'm not trying to [ __ ] on the game
I'm just frustrated with like what the
[ __ ] I just want to play the game number
one and know the [ __ ] story
Jesus [ __ ] tit my ass holy [ __ ] my
balls it's so infuriating ly frustrating
and I have no idea why whoa
okay bye okay alright there we go I
guess
and you know what I realize is that it's
gonna give me the tape after I do this
so all my time spent looking for the
tape first which you think is what you
would [ __ ] what I can't [ __ ] pay
oh my god are you kidding me
which is what you would want right it's
what you would want while you're doing
these mundane tasks whatever I'm getting
heated I'm gonna kita and I don't need
to be good tell me you go here right you
go here or are you somewhere else there
we go apparently all right you're there
how about okay and we're starting oh
[ __ ] there we are there we are okay all
right okay I'm a clean slate clean slate
not gonna let it get to me all right not
let it get into me I've got my hairdryer
I'm fine I don't even know what the
stakes are
I don't even know what I'm risk hey hey
stop
[Music]
okay well can you oh can you shut up
please okay
it's like boogeyman right there was a
lot of noise destroy hi
there was a lot of noise distractions
before and like oh I don't know if I got
that oh yeah that we're trying to stop
you from hearing things but I can hear
and see see oh what a [ __ ] god damn
it I can hear and see everything pretty
well enough I just don't know what the
threat is
I just don't know what the threat I mean
obviously that's right let us know about
coming out you can claw your eyes out
with this sticks but what's the threat
[ __ ] that's all right he did it oh
that's not good all right well gotta
keep my head on a wobble I guess oh ok
it storms up problem it is a lot like
boogeyman ok now I'm starting to fall
into the rhythm because I remember
bogeyman was very much about that the
lots of things happening at once and not
knowing the cues for the what-have-yous
ok now we're in it oh no no no no no no
no no no no
oh no no no no I don't know why don't
just shut it completely but maybe I'm a
big [ __ ] baby and I can't sleep with my
door not cracked open which to me this
is just a threat like I don't sleep with
my window whoa whoa whoa whoa my windows
aren't open none of that [ __ ] none of
that she ain't getting me doors locked
there's a love big blockade on the door
I sleep with a barricade twelve inches
of solid steel keeping me and the danger
separate and my windows a reinforced
bulletproof glass and I sleep with an
industrial slab a lead on my body at all
times and I've got a binky and a
pacifier made of bullets and glass just
try to [ __ ] with me when I'm sleeping
and they ain't gonna happen he ain't
never gonna even get close to me my
pillows made of industrial-strength c4
so if you do get to me I'm taking out
the Althea you and me I'm talking to me
in the second person and you yeah that's
right I've got one of those Bette it's a
Murphy bed I've got a Murphy bed as a
spring-trap I've actually got a dummy of
myself set up in my own bedroom I sleep
in the closet so they can be there if
there's any monsters there but if
someone goes for me on my actual bed
they get sprung into a wall of spikes
whoa
ain't nobody ain't nobody gonna get me
when I'm sleeping that's for damn sure
whoa that was silent thinks there should
be a noise there but no alas there's not
many snowmen are awfully stealthy okay
I'm almost there I think that's why why
that what happened wasn't cool what was
wetting splish splashing huh did I just
piss my pants probably yes well no don't
how do I prevent that well so what does
that do I don't know it's almost time
though so I think it's okay if I just
you know and let that be
hey hey okay
well we did it close that my mom's gonna
be pissed
Oh does this kid just not sleep this kid
just not sleep he doesn't need sleep
growing boy don't need no sleep what am
i stupid oh that is that's not okay
that's not good okay all right all my
anger about this game has been pushed
aside that's too quick all my anger has
been pushed aside slowly fine wait I
don't even get to prepare it's just
rolled right into night three oh okay
what about the store oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
oh that's not good okay well it seems to
be a lot more problematic than it once
was
whoa I melted someone preemptively holy
[ __ ] I don't know what happened okay
well just gonna stock up on these hey uh
uh uh tiny whoa whoa man they were doing
some pretty cool tricks oh well they
were just about to do some tricks and I
just melted um like an [ __ ]
it's getting dicey I don't have so many
drawings of horrible snowmen on my walls
usually usually kids draw things that
they like you know there's a nice
butterfly but it seems to be juxtaposed
by the other other horrible things is
happening here all right whoa whoa whoa
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa I heard that I
heard that I heard that I heard that I
didn't hear [ __ ] ah stop please don't no
don't do it no please I don't want to
get up all right fine for you here we go
bring it on
but [ __ ] god damn it kind of not turn on
[ __ ] [ __ ] okay well good thing we
got so much blowing his heart what if
you [ __ ] think that you're gonna get
me you are sorely mistaken and goddamn
these nights are long oh whoa whoa what
the [ __ ] is why was that
I'm blow I'm blowing I am blowing what
okay that's just existing now that's
just there that door is closed I don't
understand what the [ __ ] is going on
did it get darker seems like it got
darker whoa why no what the [ __ ] is I
whoa whoa I don't know what's happening
out there I like it
huh oh okay no no no no no I'm literally
knowing all over you okay no barely got
so many snowman I thought this is all
for good let's animate sweets we'd love
to mother nature for good oh hey okay no
that's not right they're not supposed to
be able to go through that [ __ ]
[ __ ] what's the point of even
closing the door if it's gonna go
through the door nothing you said there
were five tapes oh boy that's fast
okay just in it to win it till the very
end I suppose oh that's that's not good
i I don't know what did I don't I don't
know what what was the point of that or
whoa hey whoa whoa hey whoa okay all
right let's oh [ __ ] my dick no no the
worst time okay fine got it nailed it
all right well can't get to there there
we go so long as I'm very cautious about
my usage of my various tools oh you are
creepy you are creepy as all hell you
are [ __ ] creepy oh but I'm too good
for this game it's a goddamn good - god
damn good that's right you can open that
all you want it ain't gonna save you
when I come for you old piece of [ __ ] oh
okay I just I just [ __ ] closed that
you dick
alright whoa [ __ ] what the [ __ ] I
don't know what the [ __ ] did but here we
go
we find her we find her we find is
anybody there
hmm okay we're fine apparently man this
this nights a lot tamer than I thought
it'd be I thought it'd be pandemonium
all day long but apparently night night
all night long I'm sorry my grammar was
incorrect my usage of word was all bad
and stuff he's easy whoo hey okay that's
horrifying
all right but not bad yet I guess I knew
you were coming but I got a priority
[ __ ] oh [ __ ] all right then well these
nights are so long all right back to
life I guess okay next time the door
opens I'm just gonna leave it open just
to see if I even need to do anything
about it
I mean I have a funny feeling that it'll
kill me but it affects my strategy whoa
whoa [ __ ] you it affects my strategy a
bit if I if I have to do it okay so whoa
all right I'm watching you buddy
well you oh whoa okay okay all right
well double whammy on the same KaBlam II
order if is like horrific ly painful for
these snowmen to be melted like this cuz
it seems like it'd be pretty bad seems
like this would be pretty bad to ever
have every single part of you melt
horribly slowly it's like any of us
being burned alive and they're just
screaming silently oh no you don't know
you don't know you don't know you don't
wanna know you don't what's a new one oh
no no no no no no no no wow you are hard
to find
okay I had no idea what that was I had
no idea what that was well it was not
good
was my goddamn gold fish jumping out of
his goddamn bold whoa okay you know how
I said I was gonna just let that go I
don't think I'm gonna let that go
anymore I think I'm gonna get that Oh Oh
something was that my door on my window
walk to the window to the wall to this
last drop down my ball here we go
for realsies this time man this must be
crazy for you guys to watch because it's
just me whipping so fast back and forth
between all these but it's what I have
to do it's boogie man it's the boogie
man all over again
you're there I think I can break it up
into two sector whoo whoo hey buddy okay
I'm just gonna leave that open this is
early in the night I'm just gonna leave
it open whoa [ __ ] just gonna leave it
open I don't know what's gonna happen I
don't know if I need to do that it's
just kind of a test to see if I do I
think what it is is just it's just
another avenue for them to get in so
whoa so it's like another thing to pay
attention to but the the few seconds
that it takes to okay melt the few
seconds that it takes to look over there
is not that bad I guess but it's it's
more usage of my tools so possible more
battery usage but then again it's a lot
of time away it's so much time to close
hurry why do you take so long almost
there almost there I got this I got this
one it's in the bag not today in the bag
my bag my sack it's in my sack it's all
in my sack okay yeah
yeah yes yes oh this is turn it on full
blast anyway okay [ __ ] hell
god that's stressful that's stressful
that's like more stressful than I
remember booking man I don't know why
okay I'm assuming there's only one more
night left if I know how these are gonna
go oh you don't even give an intro for
the next snowman that's involved welp
that hallway light is gone and that is
gone early but if you [ __ ] want to
get at me you could be in the pitch
blackness of dark night oh [ __ ] okay you
could be in the pitch blackness of dark
night and I'd still be able to find you
and melt your asses so don't even think
about it don't even think about being
clever don't even think about being
smart cuz you can't outsmart me and you
can't out clever my big brain ain't
gonna do him no good I haven't seen the
new snowman yet but I can only assume
that he's an ugly [ __ ] and he's
so ugly that he's afraid to show his
goddamn face to me you piece of garbage
if I demoralize him he might either come
after me sooner or [ __ ] [ __ ] me you
might he might [ __ ] me
closing it why [ __ ] why why it's not
worth it what the [ __ ]
whoa whoa well that's a problem
oh that's a problem I've never seen
before how many other weird random
events happen in this room that I just
don't know about because I haven't seen
it I mean I do like it that's one of my
favorite things in games is when they
they do weird random events and they
don't always seem you know like they're
supposed to happen
so they surprise you you for
replayability and [ __ ] like that
oh oh that's a head okay that's that's a
head oh that's not good
well lights out in this neighborhood huh
no I'm not gonna go for it you know [ __ ]
that it's gonna leave it open it's fine
I can survive it just need more power
I'm good good gumdrop good oh god oh god
oh god oh god I don't wanna close it I'm
not gonna I'm not gonna oh my god is so
dark oh whoa oh good good thing I have
that Life Alert oh well all right pitch
blackness it is then you know what fine
[ __ ] I don't need light oh that's a
problem please
[Music]
god [ __ ] damnit see if they're melted
it just be dead there's it this game is
buggy is [ __ ] what the [ __ ] I melted
that one we're getting pretty far into
this and my eyes are open I think I saw
something there did I did I not see
something there maybe I'm going crazy at
this point which wouldn't [ __ ]
surprise me I mean I am looking at a
whole invading army of goddamn [ __ ]
snowmen [ __ ] who's that that's two of
them that's not fair that's two that's
two at once
not fair not fair gonna definitely pull
a not fair it's so close oh my god is so
close I'm just keeping this on do it
break it dawn
yes yes yes oh [ __ ] hell good golly
[ __ ] [ __ ] but they did it but I did
it buddy
[Music]
what night six you can't do that you
can't just say night six end it end it
you [ __ ] just end it oh [ __ ] okay I
guess we got to do 96 now okay yeah just
open everything turn out all the lights
get to the point already you already
know what you're gonna do
I already know what we're gonna do you
know we know I know let's just get to
the [ __ ] point already that's so
[ __ ] many of them saw Manny oh it's a
non-stop parade of snowmen giving you an
extra dose all of you even though I
probably don't need to doing it just cuz
I hate you oh [ __ ] you're not supposed
to be silent big guy all those the whoa
yeah sometimes I don't oh [ __ ] okay well
this is a lot everything's fine we're
almost there
whoo silent but deadly come on baby come
on baby come on baby whoa whoa whoa
oh [ __ ] I thought that was the door what
does it mean is there a night 7:00 and
am I just gonna roll on into that one
without any solace please tell me
Christmas but I don't want to celebrate
Christmas why do I have to celebrate
grams meals this is [ __ ]
[ __ ] you buggy [ __ ] [ __ ] that's where
this game has made me curse more than a
lot of games recently and I don't know
why [ __ ] from what is that one I'm
not seeing it uh-huh my eyes hurt my
eyes are dry my eyes are so dry it's
deserts in my eyeballs
what is that all about I saw that oh my
god oh my god I almost ten mattes hour
oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] up top bastard 420 blaze
it 420 blow it 420 time to blow it oh
that's that's not good but I don't get a
regular stream of goddamn batteries and
if my eyes don't lubricate them for
themselves properly
I'm so [ __ ] come on 30 minutes 30
minutes 30 minutes which is less than
throw God that one up there oh [ __ ]
let's go blast you and your ass yeah
that's right whoa big guy big guy how
did you get by okay we're fine we're
fine were fine yes yes yes yes yes
Christmas was a goddamn nightmare
[Music]
[Laughter]
[ __ ] whatever new thing of five tapes
oh this was an experimental title that
turned out really nicely I was a little
unsure just how scary I could really
make snowmen and if animating them
without it looking soo silly would even
work I need just giving snowmen pointy
teeth and glowing eyes was never gonna
cut it they need so much weird goofy
creepy personality to pull it off
fortunately an amazing concept artist
character artists and animators to help
me make that work so I'd very much like
to thank them all for a great game well
done this will be my last title in the
point-and-click horizontal like it's
time to move on to something fresh and
new outside of the boogieman universe so
to speak have a Merry Christmas and a
wonderful new year
barry mccabe all right I had a lot of
criticisms at first in this game but it
was good it was scary it was stress
inducing it just threw you into the deep
end just a little bit too much and then
there was just a little non refinement
in the beginning but as an experimental
title this is good it was scary those
snowmen those bastards those [ __ ]
loved him and I like this game so let me
know what you thought down in the
comments below there is a mystery door
but honestly I don't even know what that
means yeah I'll see what happens let me
let me get to the end of the credits
here and then I'll see see if there's
anything in the mystery door yeah
don't look at me I never did figure out
what that fifth drawing was about maybe
there's something else to this I don't
know oh my back okay let's see what's in
the mystery door if it'll let me maybe I
can't get to there unless I be like
nightmare mode no what could be inside
I'm so confused nightmare night
how much worse could it possibly be I
wonder probably infinitely worse god I
don't want to do this Oh No well that's
a problem as all profits the worst thing
that's the worst thing it's the worst
thing oh it's the worst thing there's a
there's a head there's a snowman's head
in air this is the worst I don't wanna I
don't wanna I'm not gonna do it just
kill me just kill me just kill me kill
me already
kill me ah you guys can try that out for
yourself if you want to give a real
challenge so whoa what the [ __ ] all
right that's that's new all right well
just quit and quitting God quit quit all
right so thank you everybody so much for
watching let me know what you thought
down in the comments below if you want
to play this for yourself I'll provide a
link the description as always and if
you got more suggestions of cool games
for me to play put them down in the
comments thank you everybody again and
as always I will see you
[Music]